you are just so ugly aren't you i've
never actually seen or been up close to
a puppy before
i'm so happy right now come back over
here
oh what's wrong
that's true honestly feel like my blood
pressure has dropped like 30 points hi
i'm steve carell and today i am going to
be answering your questions on buzzfeed
while i play with puppies can we bring
in the puppies i'd like to see the pup
oh
[Music]
oh my
okay oh you're so good
hi
okay
[Music]
now we just thought we were going to do
kind of a fun little animated movie come
back over here
oh what's wrong
come here when it came out no one had
any idea that it was going to be as
successful or popular as it was
[Music]
i'm gonna let him answer what was that
that's
true what else
could you ask a question
i did not stay oh
i did not stay in character the whole
time no
oh you are so talkative i tried out the
voice for my family and i did various
voices oh sweetheart
and uh i basically tried out the voice
on my kids the one that i landed on was
the one that made them laugh and that's
the one i use oh sweetie
i'm so happy right now
you are so noisy
[Music]
i don't watch the office i'll be honest
a lot of times the cast would get
together the first couple of seasons and
and watch them there was an episode
called dinner party one of my it was fun
to um that was a really fun one to shoot
that was a hard one to get through we
were laughing a lot we were cracking
each other up i think fans of the office
know the office way better than i do
because i i certainly have not seen all
the episodes and if i have oh you're
biting me
that was a good one
so
i don't know what i was talking about
[Music]
characters are challenging in different
ways some are some are more physically
challenging like a character i did um in
a movie called foxcatcher was
challenging in part it was a very dark
film but in part just because of all the
the makeup and you know the preparation
that went into something like that
playing michael scott was challenging in
the sense that it was over a seven year
run and to try to have a character
that uh evolved over time i you know i
guess i don't think of them necessarily
as challenging they're just different
they're all just different experiences
oh sweetie oh what's wrong
okay okay
oh
this one's going to sleep
could you find um some cuter dogs for me
to be with because these dogs are
hideous look at how hideous that dog is
[Music]
you are just so ugly aren't you
yes i like this one
not that i can think of because i
generally set my sights pretty low
hey oh look at you can i pick you up
oh sweetie
oh it's okay it's okay
you scared are you scared honey
okay i'm gonna pick you up
is that better
you okay
[Music]
wow i've never been asked that before i
think dwight was a really fun character
i can't imagine anybody but rain wilson
playing dwight i can't imagine any of
the characters being played by anyone
else but i think that's that's a fun
crazy character to play
i don't know i honestly
nothing i like i never learned how i
wish that i played i wish i took a part
where i learned how to play the piano or
juggled or something but i never maybe
out of fear i just never took part in
parts like that ryan gosling
actually learned how to play the piano
and well for a movie role that he did i
just don't i don't know if i have that
in me he's like he's like a real actor
[Music]
well that's another scene that we just
sort of laughed the whole day that
much of that movie was that way but yeah
a pig pile with me and kevin bacon and
ryan gosling like just attacking each
other um was something i never thought i
would uh take part in but was
are you biting me are you breaking me it
was sort of a fun very
very pointy
very pointy teeth they're like little
needles
wow i've never
actually seen or been up close to a
puppy before
they're all going to sleep honestly feel
like my blood pressure has dropped like
30 points seriously this is
i highly recommend this do you rent them
[Music]
for starters that would never happen
because that's like the most boring
story ever whoa look at him going to get
his dry cleaning up
he's picking his kids up from school
again that's that's a fun movie to watch
i would have ryan gosling play me only
out of uh ego he's not right for it in
any way shape or form but that would be
pretty cool and honestly my wife would
love that too
[Music]
from 2004 not many no i remember i had a
mustache that they glued on that kept
falling off because i you know have a
sweating issue and apart from that i was
just a security guard running around
saying these
confounded kids you know i was kind of
like the the dorky adult and well i
think all the adults were sort of dorky
in that movie but i was like the dorky
security guard there were like a ton of
really great people in that movie brie
larson jane lynch like they were like
across the board it was kind of a an
amazing cast
[Music]
at the time i wasn't even thinking in
terms of pivoting or i was just so
excited to get work of any kind and and
i i thought it was one of those scripts
and not that i was being choosy about
scripts either i just i got very lucky
with that that was a script that as a
cast we talked about it later we all
read it all loved it instantly and all
of our characters felt very fleshed out
and real and uh everyone seemed to be on
the same page about it was one and i
don't think a word was changed from the
time we read the script to the time we
we shot nothing was altered it was just
sort of exactly what it needed to be
that was fun that was a really fun
experience
[Music]
well we wanted it to be an actual
general store that sells sundries you
know we sell coffee and muffins and
penny candy and you know it's it's a
store that's been around since like the
mid-1800s oh do you want to come up here
too join your brothers and sisters
everybody's sleeping
there you go you want to lie down
lie down
lie down but we also you know we want to
have like
bread and milk and and things like that
i like a place people can stop in what i
love about this store is that it's it's
a throwback you know it's very analog
if you will it's where people get
together and meet each other and have a
cup of coffee kids ride their bikes
there and you know get a little ice
cream cone or something so it's it's
it's kind of a throwback it's a place
that it's the type of place i grew up
um living fairly close to um and there
are not many of them left so i just
thought to preserve it as a you know as
a piece of history but also kind of just
a neighborhood gathering place there
there aren't as many of those places as
there used to be so that was important
to me look at this
come on
now i can't leave
well i think the idea in the minions the
first minions um there's one little part
where gru and the minions cross paths
and the minions are quite taken with him
he's showing himself to be a really
promising villain in training and i
don't know the exact genesis of the
specific idea but i think it it might
have come out of that it would be
interesting to see an origin story of
how the minions and gru came together
and you know bonded and you know had
this long-term
partnership we've seen different facets
of of gru over the years you know we've
seen him kind of become a dad we've seen
him find a brother we've seen him fall
in love like all of these different
parts of his life and and to see the
genesis of it you know where
what he was like as a kid and the
genesis of you know of that character
was kind of a fun fertile ground
[Music]
probably a minion what a life you know
to go through your life with pure
unadulterated joy i mean that's
isn't that how everyone would prefer to
live i mean it's just filled with
laughter and happiness that's that's how
i see the minions i think that's a nice
way to go through life i'm feeling that
right now to be honest with you thank
you buzzfeed this
has been
the worst and i would never ever do it
again really it has made me unhappy and
stressed go see minions the rise of
group
coming
in july and please
check out pacific pups rescue these dogs
are from there i can vouch for these
dogs they are a plus plus
[Music]